TIM WILLIS: All right.
Ready to rock.
I don't have a stash of books,
let me just set up front.
So I'm going to have to
win your attention somehow.
Allow me to start
with a scenario.
So imagine that you, and
two of your colleagues,
maybe two people that you
meet here tonight, you
want to get together, and
you want to form new startup.
So in my case, I actually
chose John and Eduardo,
because they're kind of
good at what they do.
So, you trying to
think, what's on trend?
I want the hottest and
best thing on the internet
of things.
And I'm going to get
so much funding for it,
and it's going to be amazing.
So as good developers,
the first thing you do
is, you step into dev mode.
So you're sitting
there, you're just
trying to code
something out, you're
trying to get some form of
prototype up and running.
And after some extensive
user testing, which basically
involves asking your friends
about what you think is cool,
maybe some Twitter magic,
you decide on OMGAmazeballs
A beautifully simple
HTML5 front end experience
designed to make social
media more social.
I mean, wow, right?
I have no idea what any of
that means, but apparently
this idea was so crazy,
or as the kids would say,
totes amazeballs, a venture
capital firm immediately
provides you with $60 million
of pre-product, pre-revenue
funding, for 50%
ownership of your company,
providing that you can get
10,000 users in the first three
months.
And then 500,000 users
in the next six months.
Because that sounds right.
That sounds like
it's possible, right?
Totally legit.
So needless to say, this is
the reaction you would expect.
Yes.
I'm super excited.
You and your team
are super excited.
So you sit there,
squirreling away.
You do some viral
marketing, maybe set
up some fake accounts,
try to get some attention.
And before you know it,
you hit 10,000 users.
Which, as we all know,
means make it rain.
We get our first set of funding.
It's going to be amazing.
Our first pay day.
Although, that
being said, I think
there's probably
an argument to be
had with the profit
sharing arrangements.
I think I have about
$4, Eduardo probably
has just north of 10, and John
at the front, well, come on.
I think it speaks for itself.
So just as you're closing in
on 25,000 users, of course,
because that's just
easy to do, you
notice your user count
gets a bit flappy.
It starts going up,
it starts going down.
You could start to get
traffic spike, and then drop.
But your servers
are running hot.
You don't understand
what's going on.
There's a lot of traffic
going through your servers,
but your user count
isn't increasing.
So before you can
look any further,
or before you try to dig
into it, unfortunately,
because you're the new
hotness, this happens.
Someone forwards
you this article.
Newly Discovered
Weaknesses in OMGAmazeballs
reveals user info,
causes mass sadness.
So, it turns out that some
nefarious security researcher
found and exploited a cross
site scripting vulnerability
in OMGAmazeballs.
So this was a stored XSS,
as Parisa mentioned earlier,
or cross site scripting,
I'll refer to it as XSS
throughout the
talk, which allowed
them to insert arbitrary Java
Scripts into all pages that
were shown to the user.
So this JavaScript
could send copies
of all updates made to
OMGAmazeballs, including
your user data, in app user
names, passwords, anything
that the user could
do, this JavaScript
could perform on
behalf of the user.
[SIGHS]
Naturally, sadness sets in.
You get to work trying to
figure out how this happened.
I mean, the money is gone,
but as professionals you're
interested in wondering,
how did this happen?
And what can I do,
next time, differently,
to make sure that I'm not
vulnerable to this class
of bug?
Revenge?
Maybe.
But unfortunately, you look
around the site to no avail.
So you don't know
what's happened.
You don't know how the
person's exploited the bug.
So you're looking around,
you're looking in logs.
It doesn't really make sense.
Then you go to one of the
pages of your top users.
You go, OK, who's
had the most traffic?
And then you see this.
Real name, oh man, really?
So again, you were confident
that you were sanitizing data
on input, and escaping
that data on output.
But somehow, someone's injected
control tags into the page,
and just as Parisa
highlighted earlier,
they're able to load a script.
But in this case, they're
not popping in alert box.
It looks they're
loading something
from the user profile directory.
So /photos/legit.jpg.
You go and look at legit.jpg.
It doesn't open.
That's interesting.
You download it to your Linux
box, and you run file on it,
and you notice, oh, this
says it's of type text.
That's really strange.
And you have a closer look.
You open it up in a
text editor, and it's
full of nasty JavaScript.
So, we're owned.
It's done.
So this little
piece of code that
runs from the script directory,
every time this page was
loaded, basically could do
anything on behalf of the user,
and was forwarding
that information.
Needless to say, none of
you want to end up here,
but I'm sure you've been here.
So believe it or not,
cross site scripting
is the most common
bug on the internet--
the most common security
bug on the internet.
So I'm here to
talk to you tonight
about some of the most
common bugs that we
see reported by external
security researchers
under the Google
Vulnerability Reward Program
and to test out some of
your elite hacker skills
with some examples later on.
Now I lied and I said
I didn't have books.
I've got Chromecasts,
so brace yourself.
Before we can get there, we
need to have an understanding
of how these types of bugs work.
So how does it work at Google?
So this slide basically
covers the range of payments
that we make for a
single bug of that type
to security researchers.
So in a non-integrated
acquisition,
that's basically a company
that Google has purchased,
but Google hasn't move their
product onto Google systems
yet, so it's some software
stack that we've purchased
and come along for the ride,
that'll score you $100.
But all the way up to
an accounts.google.com,
typical XSS, will
score you $7,500.
And if you can get remote code
execution, anywhere on Google,
you're looking at about
a 20 grand pay day.
Note that over the period,
and you might be wondering,
yeah, well how often
does this happen?
I mean, really how
much do you pay out?
We have paid out
over 1.6 million
in cash, for the
web program alone.
Other programs at Google,
including the Chromium rewards
program, which rewards
bugs found in Chrome,
and also the patch rewards
program, which provides money
to people who submit patches
to popular open source
projects, that
patch security bugs,
we paid out over
$3 million to date.
As you can see, it's
a bit of hard work.
We've received over
20,000 reports,
and we've only found about 3,500
bugs based on those reports.
So how does it really look?
These are the days the
numbers for externally
reported bugs, in
2013, to Google.
As you can see, XSS, and XSRF
or CSRF, dominate the field.
So these are the bugs I'd
like to focus on tonight.
We do have other categories,
so mixed content, for instance,
is when you might have a page
loading of TLS, or HTTPS,
but you include
something over HTTP.
So you might be sourcing a
script over HTTP that actually
violates the
integrity of the page.
And in Chrome, sometimes you
might have seen the padlock
with the little yellow triangle
on it, that will warn you
that there's mixed content
running on the page.
The other category
includes other bugs
that Parisa was talking about
like SQL injection, remote code
execution, Auth bypass,
all of those kind of lumped
into one category, because
when they're on the slide
you can't really see them.
There's also another
category which isn't shown,
just for transparency.
That includes types of
bugs which don't neatly
fall into one specific category.
Like it might be a hybrid
type of attack, which uses
several different types of bugs.
And finally, on the
side here, info leak.
I kind of grayed
that out, but I think
it's important to give
that some context.
So at Google, we're
very conservative when
we file these types of bugs.
So an example of a but
we might file might say,
you can tell that
a web server is
running the latest
version of Apache.
You can tell that this web
server is running Apache
v2.4.9.
In and of itself, that might
be interesting information
for the developer, but if
it's the latest version,
there are no publicly
known exploits,
there's an argument
as to whether we
should be filing
those types of bugs.
So that kind of explains why
that numbers is so high, not
that we're leaking
all over the place.
So Parisa spoke about cross
site scripting, or XSS.
So what's this less
popular sibling XSRF,
and how does it work?
Well that stands for cross
site request forgery,
sometimes referred to as CSRF.
Eduardo, who's speaking next is
a information security purest,
and he finds it very offensive
that I use x in XSRF.
So I need to point
that out to you
so you don't mention
it in his talk.
He will get very upset.
C is for CSRF, X is for XSS.
So please, take
that home with you.
What does it do?
It's a class of attacks against
applications in which state
changing requests are
predictable to attackers.
What does that actually mean?
It means that it
allows an attacker
to silently perform an
action on behalf of the user,
without their knowledge,
by piggybacking
on top of a session
that they already have.
So it basically
attacks and targets
users in authenticated
applications.
So for Google, that's
a problem for us,
because our users are mostly
signed in all the time.
So if we're signed
in all of the time,
and we expect our users to
be signed in all the time,
then this type of attack
is very important to us,
to make sure that we
can mitigate against it.
So how does it work?
At a very high
level, let's say you
were using some blog platform,
of course Chromiun, or Chrome,
I should say.
And you send a request
to delete my blog.
I'm logged in, please
delete my blog.
The response, jolly
good, we'll delete it.
Winning.
We must be on google.co.uk
for this one to work.
So what's actually
happening in the background?
Well your browser
sends the request.
It has the blog ID in
it, it has the site,
and it's also sending you
cookies across with it as well.
So what the browser is doing is,
every time you make a request
to that site, if
you have cookies,
it will hopefully provide
the cookies along with along
with the request.
So here, we ask to delete
it, and our response is OK.
So what happens when someone
evil tries to do this.
So they're like, yeah,
can you delete my blog?
Totally my blog.
Seriously, it's my blog.
The response you'll get is,
not you, no cookies, no dice.
Or simply, 403 forbidden.
The reason this
happens is because you
don't have those cookies.
So if I'm an attacker,
and I'm trying
to impersonate your account,
I don't have your cookies.
So the browser does not
send the cookie along,
and therefore I get the response
that no, that doesn't work.
So taking that
into consideration,
how do we actually do an XSRF?
How does it actually
work, and how do we
attack logged in users to
perform a function that
silently happens
in the background?
Well, first thing we need
to do is set up the XSRF.
I'll show you a code snippet
later of an example of one,
but in this case,
you can either set up
your own kind of
dodgy site, and try
to get people to come to it,
which is a bit more difficult.
But what you could do
is, find a site that
allows you to
inject HTML into it.
Or find a site, which, if you
use some of the tricks Parisa
was referring to
earlier, you can actually
get it to accept
HTML that renders
in the page as the
context of that page.
Now, they are well known
cases of people doing this,
especially on forum sites,
or in comment fields.
So imagine if you could
inject this type of HTML
into the comment
field of a new site,
and then everyone who visited
that new site or saw that page,
is possibly is possibly
vulnerable to attack.
So let's say you set this up.
You set up the payload,
and you let it run.
Let's use the example
of the new site.
So then what happens is the
person requests the site.
I type it in, I hit enter.
You get the request
for the site,
and you get the HTML
returned to you.
In this particular set, you
have seen images to load.
So there are some image tags
all the way down the page,
and it loads it.
But one of those image
tags is a little bit dodgy.
One of those image tags actually
says, oh, hey server over here
that's logged in, can you
load this image for me?
I really need it for this page.
And what's actually
in that request is,
I'm asking that logged in server
up here to delete the blog.
And the request I get
back is, OK, blog deleted.
So this works because
I've enticed someone
to visit this site.
When the image loads, it's
actually not an image at all,
and it's sending a
request to a server
that I'm already
authenticated to.
And my browser, being the good
piece of technology that it is,
will send my cookies
along with that request,
automatically, because
I'm already logged in.
So what I'm actually doing
is getting this person
to initiate a
request on my behalf,
silently, in the background.
Now that might sound
a little hard core,
but that's all it is.
So here's my cool site.
If you weren't sure, the
h1 tag says cool site.
I have an amazing gif, or "jif."
We can have that
argument over a drink.
And then here, oh, I want
to load another image.
It's just at here/deleteblog.
And here's my blog ID.
And my style tag
says display none.
So it's not going to
mess up the formatting.
It's not going to give
me a broken image link.
It's going to happen completely
seamlessly in the background.
And my browser, being the good
piece of technology that it is,
is going to load this.
Load this.
This will happen secretly
in the background,
and then we get
thanks for visiting.
So that is how an XSRF works.
So you might be
thinking, how do I
defend against this
type of attack?
How can you stop
this from happening,
if the browser's going
to send the cookies?
Do I have any chance?
How is the server
going to know that it's
me sending it, like I'm
interacting with the page,
versus someone taking advantage
of this piece of technology
in order to exploit it?
Well the solution is,
use what's called tokens,
or an XSRF token.
Now a token is just a secret,
unguessable, random string,
which is generated
by the server,
and provided to the client.
So you would use this on a
state changing submission,
or something that's
very sensitive.
So if you were asking someone
to perform a transaction,
or do a post on a blog,
or you were asking someone
to change their password for
instance, what you can do
is get a user token.
The server will
generate the token,
provide it to the client, and
go, here's this random string.
And when you want to
go ahead with this,
you reply with a request, and
you also send the token along
with it.
So that way the server
knows, yes, I received it
and I'm sending it back.
So you might be like, well,
that might be hard to implement.
How do I do that?
Well, it's highly likely your
favorite framework already
has them.
Highly likely.
And you should listen
to Eduardo if you're
unfamiliar with
this, speaking next.
He'll talk a lot
about frameworks.
For those of you
who are familiar,
and I expect there are some
of you in the audience who
are very familiar
with CSRF type bugs,
please remember to test
your fail conditions.
So it's very easy to set
it up, and have it running,
and you have it running,
and you've checked it,
and it's brilliant.
And then you make some seemingly
unrelated changes somewhere
else along the website,
and suddenly the token
is not being verified anymore.
Or you could replay older
tokens from a long time ago.
So it's very important
that if you are using this,
you test your fail conditions.
All right.
So now that we've
covered XSS, and XSRF,
it's time to see your
amazing computer hacking
skills in a couple
games of spot the bug.
So I'm going to give
you two examples.
These are real bugs that were
reported under the Google
vulnerability reward program,
which received cash payouts.
The first one, I would hope most
people can spot it, and again,
if you really want
a Chrome Cast,
then you probably have to
be very quick on this one.
The second one is not
so easy, and I just
want to highlight the
complexity of some of the bugs
that we see.
So, who can see a
bug in this code?
Set isfree true.
Surely, that's
not going to work.
It works.
This is a bug from 2012, where
what actually happened was,
this was part of some
testing and this was always
validated on the server side.
But we made a seemingly
unrelated change,
and what actually happened was,
any changes on the client side
weren't picked up
on the server side.
And the server actually
just agreed with it,
and said, yeah, well,
data isfree equals true.
So this is an example of just
a security configuration.
This is an example of not
necessarily a specific type
of class of bug,
it's just making sure
that you test and
understand your code.
I'm actually not sure,
I think there's also
another bug that the person
got a free Rihanna song,
but that's a whole
nother conversation.
So in this particular
attack, the data isfree tag,
if it was set to
true on the client,
it should be ignored
on the server.
The server should
be setting that.
So in this particular attack,
what actually happened was
the server wasn't validating,
and allowed that to progress.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
TIM WILLIS: No.
Just this particular attribute
was not being checked.
So you couldn't change
any of the other things
without the server
picking up on it.
It was just this
particular attribute.
All right.
Now this is the
more hardcore one.
So to start off, how would
you escape this piece of code?
What do you need to be
careful about especially
around to user string?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
TIM WILLIS: Yes.
So you need to make sure that
these bad boys are encoded.
So the problem is that
if I need to encode it,
I need to escape it.
Because otherwise
somebody could potentially
put in another single
quote, and then they
could put in whatever
they want and run to town.
So is this all we need to do?
Should be OK?
If someone can give me a hint
why, you get one of these.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TIM WILLIS: OK.
So you need to HTML
escape as well.
Why do you need to HTML escape?
Why?
It doesn't make any sense.
You got a book and a Chromecast.
Good night for you.
Awesome.
So, it kind of depends.
So this is where the complexity
of these security bugs
comes into play.
So fun fact on browser decoding.
This is the order that
it actually happens in.
So HTML decoding first.
URL decoding.
So you know, in the
URL gets converted back
to the space character.
And then at the end you get
the JavaScript decoding,
which is what we showed earlier.
Like the /x27 for the single
quote gets converted back.
So how do we actually get here?
So this is it being
escaped, right?
So what sort of payload
would trigger an alert box.
Well, it doesn't check
the HTML encoding, right?
So what if I have an HTML
encoded single quote in there.
Then when it all gets displayed
at the end, I get this.
I basically get my
alert box to pop.
So how did that work in practice
for this specific bug reported
in the Gmail web-- this is
actually the mobile interface.
It's one of the many
mobile interfaces.
I'd send an email containing
this completely unsuspicious
tag that I'm sure
everyone would click on.
And then the page would
render, as you can see,
the page renders with
just this portion of it.
Because what Gmail
is doing is, it's
turning that into a mailto link.
So it looks like
an email address,
and so it's hopefully
turning into a mailto link.
Then when I click on it, I
could open a new compose window,
and type a mail to that person
with the email address already
pre-populated.
What actually happens
in the end is this.
You can see we've got
here, the single quote
breaks that, we get
our alert box, and then
two quotes on the end.
What does it look like?
That's what it looks like.
So there's one of our
researchers-- successfully
anonymized-- popping in
alert box on mail.google.com.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
TIM WILLIS: I would say so.
I mean, I could
hopefully make a living
on the amount of money
that was going out.
But, yeah, I think
there are people
who are professional
bug bounty reporters.
But they usually report to
lots of different programs.
So I couldn't comment
authoritatively
on whether they make
a living doing it.
So if you're feeling a little
like this about all the stuff
I've spoken about, like
this is just crazy,
I didn't even understand
that last slide,
what the hell is going on?
Don't despair.
Because these problems have
really cool and easy solutions,
believe it or not.
And solutions that you can take
home with you tonight and start
using immediately.
Because after the
break, these two guys
are going to show you how easy
it can be to protect yourself
from security vulnerabilities
in your applications
without even having to
really understand how they're
exploited, or write any
security specific HTML5 code.
Sound too good to be true?
Well, actually I have
time for questions.
So why don't we
all grab a drink,
and aim to be back
here just on 8 o'clock.
Thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]